it's Lana hood the current tester eNOS
Petri says she's excited to be meeting
someone new today because you never know
what they'll be like
woman wonders what's used to wear in
such a first blind date
so she's brought a full selection so she
could decide later on the spur of the
moment robust athletic minimalistic
elegant they're all on hand and so is
her date which aims to capture her heart
with adventure and diversity
Hyundai's eye 20 active crossover model
it's based on the five-door version of
the standard i-20 but the designers have
given it a silver underride guard in the
front and rear and black plastic
components on the sides for a look all
its own
penises first impression she likes what
she sees the engineers have raised the
i-20 active chassis by two centimeters
the cars additional components make it
two centimeters longer as well will it
live up to its attractive exterior the
roof rails make it possible to carry
additional bulky luggage this is a car
for the active life a dapper gentleman
but also a sportsman
of course appearances and everything
says eNOS it's the inner values that
count and in a car that's the engine
here Hyundai has engaged in downsizing
like this sandal this version has trim
material away and traded the 1.4 liter
engine in for a one liter one it as
wonders how that affects performance but
since the naturally aspirated engines
have been replaced by turbochargers the
car is a little sportier it's now got
more torque so it gets quickly moving
even is test of the i-20 active with a
newly developed 1 liter turbo petrol
engine in the lower 74 kilowatt
performance level this engine is
supposed to consume just 4.8 liters per
100 kilometers it's advantage is 172
Newton meters of torque available from
1500 rpm on up hande steers very
cooperatively it's agile and takes every
curve well
but eNOS would have liked a bit more
temperament at high speeds
she says the i-20 active is demanding
when it comes to shifting gears the five
gears need to be used very actively
especially if you want to get somewhere
quickly
now she'll test the Honda off-road the
crossovers higher ground clearance
enables it to surmount minor unevenness
effortlessly and the driver sits a bit
higher - which provides a good overview
of the situation but this car is less
adventuresome about daring maneuvers for
example with a wheel up in the air or
very rough ground
the i-20 active doesn't have all-wheel
drive inna says so forget roughing it in
the mountains
the interior is generously outfitted the
Hyundai has provided the i-20 active
with high quality durable surfaces
everything feels good to the touch the
metal clad pedals underscore the i-20
actives individual character the car is
roomy in front and back the rear seat
sits three
the trunk isn't stingy with space either
even the glove compartment is large
enough to stow penises pumps penis
concludes at the Hyundai i20 active is a
great all-round vehicle for everyday use
returning to her shoe theme she remarks
that sometimes the ones you're already
wearing are perfect but just to be sure
she'll take your pumps along after all
with this new acquaintance you never
know what adventures waiting around the
bend
you